adam is in lake city florida hi adam
welcome to the ramsay show hey dave hey
uh thank you for uh
taking my phone call our pleasure sir
how can we help
i am currently on babysit two and
out of all my debt my vehicle is over 50
of it so i am trying to sell it i'm
thinking about selling it
what do you however it's the end of my
it's the highest thing all my debt is
the last thing i need to pay off
what do you owe i owe 17
4 on it and what's it worth about
13 12. the few the few people that i've
reached out to
for a quote have been quoting me between
12 and 14.
okay so that's a wholesale at a dealer
right they're trying to buy the card
wholesale
correct so if you look up kelly bluebook
kbb.com
for private sale if you put it on
craigslist that means it's going to
bring 15. yeah
i i believe kelly blueblook is running
16 to 18.
there we go so yeah we're fourteen
hundred dollars often
all right so what's your income uh forty
forty thousand eight hundred i'm not
including my side hustle
you said 40 800 uh
usually yes sir okay so 41 grand all
right and then you got a side hustle
that makes you what
roughly 2 000 a month okay two rules of
thumb we use
one is is the value of your vehicle more
than half your annual income
you do not violate that but you come
close yep
number two can you be 100 debt free if
you keep this thing
other than your home within uh
two years and you probably can do that
yes sir i think my date is july of 2022.
just with your side income you can
probably do it this year yeah
do you like do you like the car i
i don't like the payment more no i know
but do you like the car
yeah um not really i mean
it gets by it gets me by that has to
suck making a car payment on top of
something you don't even like
man yeah well that might be reasonable
that might be reason to move down let me
tell you why why i came up with the
two-year thing
and let this you percolate on this and
anthony you join in
okay but my reasoning is if the car
is going to keep you in debt for an
extended period of time
past the two-year you're trying to run a
race with ankle weights on
okay you're not in that but you're
carrying a fairly heavy weight you got
one brick in your backpack anyway right
and so you got something to carry here
because you're gonna make it but like
you said it's half
of your debt and you can clear that
on something you don't even like that
much anyway then i might do that now
here's the downside here here's the
reason i try to project this out
just past because we don't get people
out of debt just for getting out of debt
we get you out of debt so you can become
wealthy
and guess what happens as you become
wealthy you're going to move into a
better car
okay so if you move down out of this car
into a
into a beater and 18 months from now you
move back into another car that you pay
cash for
of similar price which is really about
the schedule you would be on
uh it really was it was you know it's
kind of just a little two-step here
it wasn't like a big deal move yeah now
if you told me you're making 40 and you
owe 50 on the truck
sucker's gone yeah blow it up i mean
it's done
okay you completely screwed up doing
that but that's not your case
so um what kind of car is it adam what's
a truck
look at this chevy silverado sure oh i
mean that's a good that's a good car
though yeah nothing wrong with that
truck yeah nothing around
but he doesn't like it so yeah i'm sorry
the whole idea is if you're gonna turn
around around 18 months later move back
up anyway and you like the car then i
would say fight through and keep the car
but you don't like the car so
you're going to move out of the stupid
thing in 18 months anyway once you're
debt-free you're probably going to move
out of it right
correct let's go and move out of it now
and accelerate debt free
i i agree now what's out of the debt
though adam
i'm sorry what's the other debt uh
credit cards and some personal ones okay
cool great yeah sell the car man
go ahead and sell the car now once you
sell the car do you have cash
to buy another car yeah you got to get
you had a little cash set aside for a
beater
yes right that was the other that was
going to be the follow-up question
yeah you push pause on your baby step to
pile up some cash to transact this right
okay now how do i go about deciding
what price level i need to be saving up
for
i mean i mean i understand it's a beater
and everything but a couple of grand
that's what requires a work
couple of grand yeah okay and it may not
be a truck adam what's your side hustle
i uh deliver groceries through uh a
company
an online company are they requiring a
certain age of car
uh no okay they just require low
reliability
correct yeah so two to three grand yeah
two
three yeah cause this is not a car
you're gonna keep it has no sex appeal
but has reliability
it's a car you give a name to
okay old blue got me through when i was
getting out of debt and delivering
groceries you tell your grandkids this
story someday i'm back in the day i had
old blue
right yes sir and take pictures of it
because you want to remember the
sacrifice
absolutely i wish i had pictures of some
of those crap cars i drove and i was
straightening this stuff out man
trust me i got mine it motivates me
yeah so but that's what yeah so you hear
all the different variables variable
number one he doesn't like the car
variable number two
it um it's half as debt uh variable
number three he doesn't like the car so
yeah yeah he's got a good side hustle so
yeah bust it pile up three grand four
grand
1400 to cover the the whole three grand
to buy you a little something
and let's put this thing on craigslist
get her sold and uh don't
buy something till you get her sold yeah
and then just work like crazy to get out
of that while you're waiting to get it
sold when it sells
don't give it away we're not trying to
sell do not sell it for wholesale
there's no reason you're not about to be
repo'd
so don't give away don't sell a 16 000
truck for 12 000 to a dealer right
and create another 4 000 problem for
yourself there's no point in that the
dealer's not doing anything wrong
they're just trying to make a living but
they they buy cars cheap so they can
make a
make a profit when they resell them they
don't buy them at retail
and let me say this to america i know
you probably hear some of you all who
are new to us
dave did not say skip over the the small
debt and go pay off the card
what he's saying is good still work the
baby steps but while you're working
the baby step method paying off all you
did from smaller to largest
sell the vehicle so he's not putting no
more money on top of that one
but in order to do that we really put
baby step two on hold for a second
exactly pile up cash to get the car and
to do the other
but then that releases him from this
larger debt right
so in a sense the 1400 hole he is in
becomes an item in the debt snowball and
moves to the front there it is
that's in a sense what we're doing we're
instead of the whole 17 000 debt yes
it's the 14 1400 hole and so that's
that's the way i
the logic flow works on this the
critical thinking
skills yeah adam you're good man you're
good you got this baby
knock it out man knock it out
this is the ramsay show